in the streets of myanmar
weapons of war
[Music]
in medina unarmed protesters shelter
from
bullets
[Music]
people against an army
security forces commanded to shoot to
kill
according to activists and a police
officer who fled from myanmar
foreign
[Music]
in this video security forces take turns
taking shots you can hear the terror of
the people
filming
in another a commander appears to be
pointing out
targets to a sniper
these clips are among 55 which rights
group amnesty
say are evidence of troops using
increasingly lethal
tactics and weapons against protesters
they accuse the military of premeditated
and
systematic killings a charge it denies
here a man in white is being led away by
police
he isn't resisting but suddenly he's
killed
[Applause]
it's too graphic to show he's shot
at close range this is a military that
has
marauded around ethnic minority areas
for years
uh with impunity so for us what we're
trying to do is the best we can to
document what's happening there but
there really needs to be a strong united
action taken by the international
community to ensure that no
further blood is shed
but while the protesters wait for action
the violence
continues
as a military determined to exert its
control
unleashes an increasingly bloody
crackdown
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok